I guess October is like the jobs that I
will never ever do month
I mean astronauts no thank you
African boating captain Phillips is
directed by Paul Greengrass the director
of United 93 Bourne Supremacy Bourne
Ultimatum and green zone it stars Tom
Hanks who is a certified awesome person
and he's probably one of my favorite
actors out there in fact he definitely
is and this is the true story of a
boating captain played by Hanks is
travelling around the African coast
that's taken over by real-life
modern-day pirates and the thrilling
situation that ensues afterwards and
we're not talking about pirates in the
fun sense of the word where they get on
board and they're like why is all the
rum gone it's more like a bunch of
savage men who will kill you instantly
without a shred of humanity actually
that is kind of like Pirates of the
Caribbean pirates it's more serious is
what I'm trying to say now Paul
Greengrass to me is one of the only
directors out there he uses handheld
shaky cam and makes it look like an art
form and not a gimmick he is extremely
good at using that form of filmmaking to
enhance his films and he does a great
job with Captain Phillips I think this
is one of his best films I think this is
one of the best performances I've seen
from Tom Hanks which is saying a lot
because that man has two Oscars already
the man seriously brought real flowing
man tears to my eyes in this movie he
did such a terrific job with his
performance it's the kind of performance
that is so brave that you don't see this
type of thing in film too often because
for a large portion of the movie it
really is like a straight thriller and
it's excellent at doing that but there
is a portion of the movie that gets very
dramatically heavy that just really
affected me and I got to say captain
Phillips is one of the best films I've
seen this year for a strict thriller
that is weighted by a terrific
performance this movie does everything
it sets out to do very well this isn't
the type of film that has hidden
meanings and hidden metaphors and all
these various things you could take from
it this is a film that tells a true
story fairly accurately I've done some
research on it and I've realized there
are certain things they emitted and the
filmmakers have been completely open
about certain things that were omitted
they're not trying to hide it
they got the essence of what happened
very correct in my opinion and I think
that the filmmakers the writers and the
actors did such a great job at
portraying a sense of realism and that's
one of the best things that Paul
Greengrass brings to movies as a real
sense of an environment that feels as if
it's palpable that you're actually there
you could feel the heat and the sweat of
the situation that's something I really
enjoyed about captain Phillips and that
only comes from people who know how to
make a film and who know how to act in a
scene and inhabit a character and
speaking of that the men who played the
Pirates I thought were fantastic and I
believe this was all of their first
performances which is really impressive
because I honestly believe like you look
at these guys and you're like it's not
just the makeup and the clothing these
guys felt like savages and they did such
a terrific job at portraying real-life
modern-day pirates that I honestly
believe they were and that is really
impressive for people who are in their
very first movie ever and who are
obviously new to this situation and
they're just innocent with Tom Hanks and
you got to intimidate Tom Hanks with
your gun so do it these guys did such a
great job and I was just completely
impressed all around with the
performances in this film Tom Hanks is
at that point in his career where it's
hard to not see Tom Hanks you know there
are certain actors out there that are
very good at what they do but they're so
famous that it's very difficult to be
like that's Tom Hanks that's Tom Cruise
apparently Tom's
are very famous but this movie was so
well made and so realistic that I bought
into that person and I started to care
about that character not just because
Tom Hanks is the awesome likable guy I
cared about the character and that is
what you need in a good movie because
you can have a terrific thriller you can
have a fun movie but if you don't care
about the central character or any of
the characters now that's going to
matter and Captain Phillips is a movie
that makes you care and that's one of
the reasons why I was thrilled from
start to finish in this film and I think
it's one of the better films that came
out this year I'm going to give it an
a-minus I think the only issues with the
film that I really had were it might be
a tad too long but I think that they did
a terrific job with everything that
could have done and I really enjoyed the
movie so guys I hope you see the film
when it comes out and let me know what
you thought of it below if you have seen
it thanks as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes